to former president Donald Trump's
unprecedented Journey from the White
House to the courthouse he is expected
to turn himself in on Tuesday following
his historic criminal indictments
Trump's most fervent allies and Capitol
Hill are showing their support by
calling the indictment a political witch
hunts on Friday the Manhattan district
attorney warned House Republicans
against attempting what he called
unlawful political interference in the
case in New York security is tight
around the Manhattan Courthouse where
Trump's attorney says the former
commander-in-chief will surrender
Robert Costa is there Bob good morning
good morning Jeff Lower Manhattan
remains on high alert this morning as
NYPD officers prepare for possible
protests next week when former president
Trump arrives right here for his
arraignment on Tuesday and while the
indictment remains under seal on Friday
we did begin to learn more about the
scope of the charges
former president Donald Trump is slated
to appear before a Manhattan Criminal
Court Tuesday afternoon where he's
facing what could be a sweeping
indictment One Source says the
indictment could contain over 30 counts
related to the alleged falsification of
business records to cover up hush money
payments made to adult film star Stormy
Daniels ahead of the 2016 election by
now we all know the basic Contours of
the scheme the decision to pay Stormy
Daniels hush money and mischaracterize
it as legal fees to Michael Cohen
Trump's lawyer says the former president
stands ready to fight the charges ones
that he believes are politically
motivated this is a case that would not
have been brought against another
individual in this country if his name
wasn't Donald Trump pursuing pursued by
a prosecutor who has uh obviously very
diverse political views from the
president that sentiment has been echoed
by many Republicans I think the
unprecedented indictment of a former
president of the United States for a
campaign Finance issue is an outrage
this is going to destroy America we're
going to fight back at The Ballot Box
we're not going to give in including
Trump himself untrue social
on Friday Council for Manhattan D.A
Alvin Bragg sent a letter to House
Republicans denouncing Trump's attacks
on Bragg's office and urging Congress to
let the criminal justice process proceed
without unlawful political interference
sources say Bragg has compiled reams of
documents detailing numerous alleged
Financial schemes in Trump's orbit
including others beyond the hush money
payments made to Stormy Daniels by his
former fixer Michael Cohen
Bob what can we expect to see on Tuesday
when the former president turns himself
in
anyone else coming in for processing he
will enter the building behind me he
will get fingerprinted he will get a mug
shot and then he will have an open
arraignment in court the one thing he
will not have are handcuffs on his
wrists because secret service will be
alongside him at every turn
and Bob what more can you tell us about
the security precautions that are being
taken here
right now even though it's early on
Saturday morning NYPD officers are out
in full force when you walk around these
blocks they are in full uniform that's
by order NYPD officials want to make
sure that people coming to this area of
Manhattan are aware that they have a
presence metal barricades are up
everywhere and they are getting ready
for protests some of the republicans in
Congress have already pledged to come
down here and be here to Rally around
Trump
all right Bob before you go quickly so
we know the president's already running
he's given campaign speeches for 2024.
how does all this change the 2024
presidential race
[Applause]
term Jeff you see that a lot of
Republicans are rallying around Trump
they're saying he's still going to be
our pick for the nomination in 2024 but
behind the scenes it's fascinating when
I talk to donors and even some activists
and party officials they believe Trump
eventually because of this investigation
investigations in Washington could
become increasingly politically
vulnerable by the summer or the fall so
it's a wait and see moment for many
republican rivals
Robert Costa at the Manhattan Criminal
Court this morning Bob thank you